come out I'm so sorry flat kids what the  chill funny is because I love science  class we can't let these guys take us  out our first game with trash talk they  keep yelling did you since to teach you  that move but she did teach me that move  yeah your sister can ball they couldn't  remember to worried leprechaun that's  what they were trying to call me they  keep saying you're never gonna play  college ball we're just old guys I was  didn't trash talk by the Rev we got a  clap back with our own trash talk  excited well nothing I went to all saw  MVP now this is too specific none of  mine are even quiet reason I just let my  game to talk about this it's time for  shop class because I'm getting all those  going know what just go right straight  out of County any more kids  [Music]  da roasted hey you guys are not good at  basketball is that you I can tell with  the joke come on get out Africa was fun  so check out Momo